all right savannah
savannah where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from uh north
carolina winston-salem winston-salem and
tell me about your family growing up you
had mom and dad yeah um my mom and my
dad
they met in a.a
and
really because of the rooms i'm here
they even got married in a rehab
i was the flower girl um
yeah they were my dad was addicted to
crack cocaine and my mom was addicted to
opiates
pills
how would you describe your childhood
um
my childhood would be i would say
unsheltered
i got a realistic view
of
the world i think
but i also
my parents tried you know they tried to
get help even even though they would
fall again and again they tried and i
appreciate them for that
and they loved me
tried to protect me as best as they
could
but um it was hard it was very we didn't
have the most money and
we were scraping for change all the time
you know
moving from here to here dad in and out
of jail mom you know had a kind of was
forced to get it together um breadwinner
dad would pawn everything on christmas
you know
wake up everything gone mom would have
to go buy it all back kind of deal
you made it through high school i did
make it through high school what kind of
kid were you in high school
um i was
a very
not present uh person in high school i i
missed a lot of classes and a lot of
stuff um most of the times i was
either drunk or high
you know
running away a lot i ran away from my
problems with all the drugs that were in
your family at a young age were you was
there any abuse or anything um there was
no um
no
sexual abuse from my family or anything
like that that i experienced
nothing like that for my family
and after after school you went where
after school
um after high school yeah through high
school after high school i
after high school my father
i got a phone call that my dad had um
od'd
that they had found him dead
[Music]
and i
i kind of went off the rails i got
really into cocaine and crystal meth um
i met
a man who i felt you know stupid and
fell in love with
and his brother ended up
pimping me out
later on in a crack house
in kingston
so
um that's what happened and
um
you know i
i uh
nobody would tell me what to do you know
nobody everybody had like left and
i couldn't blame them
my mom i remember calling my mom and
asking her
please please tell me like for once i
really want to hear what you have to say
and
and your guidance and she told me i
can't make that decision for you
so um
i made a phone call and
they
i'd never flown anywhere and they flew
me out to california
i had to get a friend of mine to sneak
and meet me somewhere to pick me up so
the brother wouldn't find out and
you came out here for what reason um i
came out here for treatment i came out
here for
rehab
and when i came out here
i managed to
almost have three years
[Music]
you know when i came out here i had no
financial support whatsoever from anyone
i didn't know anyone out here
i was scared i was really scared i'm
from a very small town and this is a
really big city
but
my mom
my mom had
financially like you know she was
dependent on me at that point
and she came out here and i started
working you know immediately at 19 and
in treatment and substance abuse
you know
and i was working so much so much and
not making it um
i wasn't making it
i was she was living with me we were
living in the same bed um i was so in
debt didn't have
i was struggling really bad i was really
depressed
and
i
told myself of an easy and fast way to
make some money
and um
i'm really ashamed of that like i put
myself back out there but you know i'm
not ashamed either because i did what i
felt like i needed to do
for me and my mother
it might have
so i did i started um
working as
started getting back into prostitution
and
when i did that
i would come home and i'd make sure you
know the bills would be paid and extra
money in the pocket mom would have
her food and her cigarettes and
everything would be cool
but i would be in the bathtub scrubbing
my skin off with bleach you know like
um and i was doing it sober
at first and
i couldn't do that so
for long
and
one one of the guys that
i had a date with
he offered me some
coke or some crystal and
it was off to the races again
i tried to keep it under wraps and try
to control it and i couldn't
and i lost everything
lost everything became homeless again i
was sleeping on friends couches here and
there
and
i
started shooting
which i really regret
i regret doing that
math
yeah yeah math yeah
um
that
is a sensation like i pray nobody
feels
because it's really hard to shake
um
i went into psychosis i had eight
psychotic breaks
um
ambulance police were caught on me
multiple times
i
i was drugged i was given something else
other than crystal by this
by this
girl i met
who um
was trying to
i think get me down to tijuana
um she kept trying to pay my friend
and heroin to get me down there
to convince me to go with her
and her friend
had shoved a bunch of drugs up inside me
luckily like
you know i freaked them out and you know
they got out but
it was very it was really scary um it
was a scary experience for me and
in
yeah i finally decided i was like okay
i'm gonna try again i'm gonna try to get
sober again you know and do that
and you know i had actually gotten
everything back like even ten times more
i was working a wonderful job that could
turn into a career
i
had a car finally after years of not
having one out here and taking the bus
for four or five hours
you know every day to and from work
um
and
i mean i was i was happy i felt like i
mean everything was going right
everything everything was going perfect
and then one day
i just walk off my job
i walk off my job
to go pick up
crystal which they didn't have i got
[ __ ] on
and then i got crack
for the first time and i fell in love
with that
um
and ever since then you know i i haven't
been able to stop honestly i haven't
wanted to stop um
even though i know that
the pain relief
is only temporary
it's
if
i i feel like i i
i don't want to feel that pain anymore
um
the pain that you're trying to
hide from is what
um
i i've been having a lot of um
well one my dad's death has really
really affected me um
have been so responsible for my mother
and doing it all on my own and it's worn
on me
um
and
when i was 18 um
four got four guys held me down um and
raped me
um
and then i mean when you work in
prostitution i mean
you're gonna get
prostitutes do you get raped it happens
um
you know it's
it's it's hard and i didn't i didn't
realize how much it had really affected
me you kind of get like this
dissociation or something
and
but
i started getting really angry angry at
men
and
you know i wouldn't make a lot of money
because i just you know i'd
hate them surely hate it
um
it was hard um and i think that's like
the biggest thing i've kind of come into
terms with now is just
i'm just really angry
and i don't really feel anything but
anger
um
i don't know it's just uh
it's been tough it's been really hard
and everyone around me i mean i have
certain people you know i have people in
my life that love me and and want to see
me
you know
back where i was
or in a better place but
i don't think they understand like
i kind of find peace down here
you know it's um
non-judgmental
but at the same time it is very scary
and it can be
like i have to keep a lock on my tent
and like you know i've woken up with
bruises and
and
a lot of them don't like being told no
or
you know somebody some of them can flip
in the switch i mean people are using
drugs i mean drugs escalate i mean
it's just it can be very dangerous i've
had my [ __ ] stolen so many times
being a white woman on skid row yeah
very very difficult it's been tough like
i
once i got out here
um
i'd go blocks down to like go pick up
and and they would know me
and i'd be like how do you guys know me
you know um i have like about 30 to 50
cars stopping me a day
even when i'm sitting in my tent even
when the tents close they come up to the
tent i mean i guess someone told them
um
it's exhausting
uh you've been on skid row for a whole
lot
i've been on skid row for
i would say
it's been like two two and a half months
three maybe
my time is not the greatest
i don't even know what day it is to be
honest with you
um but yeah you're still
entertaining men
for money
um yeah but i
i go i try to go to people that
i've used in the past regulars and and
men that
have a lot of money
um that i can hustle um kind of like
projects honestly um
now but
if i need a hit though and i don't have
one
hell yeah i'll get in your car
that's just the truth i mean
you know if i'm in need if i'm hungry
like whatever the case is like that's a
way to make a quick thought yeah
tell me about hustling a
a wealthy man
um what does that look like
it it can and for me
it's like almost like payback
it's almost a payback um
hustling sometimes you have a partner
sometimes you have like a man partner
who helps you you know in hustling or
keeping you protected
um sometimes you
it's just really an art of okay they
want
it's not about
excuse my language it's not about you
know having sex with them it's about
like [ __ ] their mind up you know
really
getting that mind before anything else
and
just
i mean
you make them feel comfortable you know
make them feel comfortable make them
feel loved listen to them hear them
you know and each one's different each
one wants something different you have
to be kind of a chameleon you got to
change with it
you got to be able to
kind of be a mirage and whatever
be able to tell what that person wants
and
do it right you know be able to give
that to them
and just
you know for me
i like honest work so like as long as
they
everything stays the same and they're
honest about what they want i'm honest
about what i want it's a fair number you
know um and everyone's respectful cool
i'm all right with that but
if they step over the line in any way
i'm totally gonna hustle them i'm
definitely going to get
all of it
um
you know
and i don't really feel bad for that
i don't um
as far as the ones that
have hurt me
do you have a story you can share yeah
i'll share one um
so it's gonna be funny if he sees this
later on but so currently um i've been
hustling this guy for like the past
three months
um
originally when we met it was going to
be an exchange like i i told him from
the get-go like you know i'm a
ho like you know i don't do feelings or
anything but i do
product you know product money you know
needs some help here there whatever
um
i haven't touched him or let him touch
me in two months and he still pays for
everything he pays for everything
he buys my drugs buys my buys with me
whatever i want clothes
um
you know
i
he leaves his stuff open leaves me in
his house by myself i go through his
[ __ ] take more money
um
he's in love
and i'm not
i'm in love with his
i'm in love with
his wallet i'm in love with his means
that helped me
currently um i
have no emotions on drugs
really so i just don't care he sat and
cried and sobbed in front of me and told
me you know about how much
he loves me and all this [ __ ]
and i just don't give a [ __ ] honestly
i
told him from the get-go now it would be
different if i had like done a bunch of
[ __ ] but i told him i was honest up
front
didn't listen which makes him love you
more probably
yeah
um
so you know and you know i've even like
what's crazy is like you know i've
called this guy all types of names i've
humiliated him i've done a lot of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] to him
because i'm angry at men right now and
and he's kind of controlling he tries to
be
but i don't think he realizes he can't
really control me
so especially on drugs
um he in fact liked me doing drugs
because of you know sexual
heightensies
so
now i can't tame it now i can't control
it it's out of his hands
um
but he doesn't leave
so
like that's one of them that's one
hustle
and there's been many more you know
it just depends
it just depends a nice guy i won't do
that too
but
a guy that pisses me off absolutely
holiday i'm 22. you're 22. oh my god
you're so seasoned for a young girl
yeah well my parents were older when
they had me and i grew up with my
grandparents son too
i did i will say that um
i i do appreciate
that
my parents didn't just
have a bunch of money and throw throw
throw me to a nanny or something like
that i'm really happy that um
even though they were strung out and
even though all that [ __ ] happened
um
they did try to teach me
they just teach me and they tell me well
about respect and loyalty
morals a code you go by
um god
um
what do you think made you so angry at
men
the fact that they made me realize that
i am not invincible
that i'm not bulletproof and that they
took something from me
without having the right to take it um
do you think your work as a sex worker
has created that
that's where they came from
um no well when i was uh that happened
originally when i was
um
sex trafficking in north carolina
because that was unwillingly
now a lot of times so what happened to
north carolina that got you into this
um the
brother of uh the guy i was seen when i
was 18 um he had oh he's one who kind of
got you into it yeah you feel like you
were
yeah no and then that's when the rape
happened so
um
when that happened i didn't realize how
much and a lot of times women that have
gone through that or have been into
some type of sex trafficking or sex work
a lot of times they will return to it um
they will um
i don't know why it's weird it's like
it's weird in how ways it affects you
but
i don't know i feel like each year or
each time i relapse or end up
running back to chaos
i feel a little like my heart's a little
bit colder each time
my heart used to be like really really
warm
and it still is it still is i wish it
wasn't sometimes
but
this time
i feel a lot colder
than any time before so
i don't know i feel like uh i don't know
if this is a valley or
a pit i've fallen into or
i'm sure there's a lesson
um
in the midst um
but i'm just gonna take it a day at a
time i guess living on skid row and
addicted to crack and and doing sex work
puts you in a dark place
there's no way around that yeah no it
definitely it definitely does
um and i think like after
it does but at the same time you know i
find it very beautiful
and i'll say this um
i love waking up in the morning
and smiling at everyone
and like seeing these beautiful people
down here smile back and how
a lot of them they're not greedy and a
lot of them are here to help you i i
mean since i've been down here i'm young
and i'm you know
you know i'm kind of a target and um
i've had so many women and
people look and manny to
look out for me just as much as the ones
that are kind of after me too
and i really appreciate that
yeah so i mean there is i i still have
faith in humanity
and that's one thing i do love about
down here you know it might get scary at
night
but in the morning it's always beautiful
yeah it's a very different place at
night than it is
during the day
do you have any friends
i do
i do i have um friends down here um
friends who have become like family to
me
um
i'm very grateful for them
um because it does it can get really
lonely
sometimes
like when i'm in the tent and i'm just
in there
i'm just
sometimes it gets lonely what do you
what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is
my biggest fear is losing my mom
my mom actually
had a procedure this morning that i was
supposed to
take her to or i was supposed to help
her with
but instead i sat in the car all night
smoking crap
and i feel like [ __ ] because of it but
at the same time i can't stop
i just hope she's okay
that's the correct behavior that gets
its reputation as being so scandalous
yeah yeah you i'm sure you wanted to be
there your intention your intention was
to be there and that's the crazy part
about it is like you know
my everything feels robotic
it feels
like like something takes over you know
it's it's like i can mean everything in
me every fiber in me that i'm going that
i'm going to be there i've told her over
and over you know i promise you i will
not miss this i knew how scared she was
for it
and i just sat and i sat and i sat
and i looked for crack and i searched
the floorboards and
i
you know
i just couldn't get it together i
couldn't it scared me being away
from here
because i knew i'd have a harder time
finding it
and i didn't know how i was going to
deal with
my mom being
going through that
your parents were in love with each
other
my mom and my dad were soul mates
as my mom says
honestly when they were sober together
oh my god it was beautiful
um
they were like big kids you know um they
were
oh
it was he my dad was so respectful
um and so funny i mean he could make
anyone laugh
um
and my mom i mean she's just like this
such a peaceful
you know
go with the flow type of type of person
but she's also very strong
you know and my dad
was he was just
the greatest guy you'd ever meet i mean
just anyone's best friend he could be
best friends with anyone
uh when they were sober they were
amazing
um
when they weren't
you know that's when
sometimes i believe
god sends angels down to earth
and then
sometimes we those angels can turn into
monsters
and god has to take them back
and turn them into angels again i think
that's what happened to my dad
i've i never thought i'd be
scared of my hero you know i never
thought i'd be
scared of daddy um
but
he got violent towards the end
and i ended up in foster care for
a year
because my mom had become suicidal at
that point and it was unsafe for me to
be in either household
um
and then you know once i was 18 i mean
it was off and
i was running you know i was i was
staying at friends houses i i just i was
going anywhere i could but most the time
i was getting kicked out because i could
never i could not follow rules for [ __ ]
like i just can't
you know i'm really
i don't have a control problem with
others wanting to control others but i
definitely want to be in control of
myself
i watched my mom get controlled for like
13 years being married to my stepfather
and
she was so depressed miserable
i said that never be me
so maybe that's why i buck so much maybe
that's why i
fight the man so much my dad also taught
me like when i was younger he said never
be scared of a man
and i got scared of them and now i'm
taking it back
so
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret would be
not getting
not getting to
not getting to see my dad
before he died
not getting to
hold him or
you know
not being able to
i waited so long so no one could you
know keep him away from me you know like
you know we could finally be together
and you know i always had hope for my
dad
i always thought he'd get better
i really did
and to have hope and faith and
fearlessness like that
and then and wake up one morning and one
phone call
just takes it all away
it was awful feeling
that would be my biggest regret
that and
that and and putting myself out there
um
when i was sober
uh doing this sex work and stuff again
i wish i wouldn't have done it
because it caused me a lot of pain like
a lot of it it caused myself a lot of
pain have you been in love before huh
have you been in love before
yeah most definitely um i've definitely
been in love
before um
and
you know i mean it's like
it's like that kid that doesn't want to
go to prom you know because they're
afraid they're gonna embarrass
themselves or whatever but you know
they have to take that risk because
they all miss out on the dance that's
what my mom always says like that garth
brooks song or some [ __ ] you know she's
real southern
where do you see your life going from
here you're still young but
um what do you what do you think where
do you think you'll be in three five
years
well
honestly part of the reason why i
haven't wanted to get help or get sober
is because i feel like i'm in the same
pattern my dad was
and i just don't see the point if it's
going to happen eventually
but
i figure
in three to five years either
i will be
either i will be
[Music]
i really wanted to become a paralegal
um i really wanted to become
i really wanted to work for the i had
like big dreams and [ __ ] of like wanting
to go and work for the innocence project
and
you know change things about the
department of corrections and department
of justice
fight racism
because it was very
it's still very heavily present
especially down south
and
i've always had a passion about that
or in three to five years
i could be
maybe i'll be with my dad i don't know
we'll see
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
the most important lesson
that i have learned
is forgiveness
to be able to forgive myself
to be able to forgive others
to let go
you know i think people will get really
you know a lot of my friends you know
they're very like worked up and and
stressed out about so many things and i
just
i let it go
um
not to
have hatred
hold power i don't hate people you know
i mean well [ __ ] man i just said i ain't
mad but you know
just like
i don't know like
i just
no matter how cold my heart might
feel like it's getting
there's always a warm spot still
and
i just hope that warm spot
can grow a little bit bigger and bigger
um
because i do
like the person who i was
and hopefully i can get back to her
one day
but right now
yeah
this is what i got
this is who i am who i got
like kind of jekyll and hyde situation
the only thing that can
save me from this would be god i would
believe
i think
that's that's all i can hope for
i mean
that's where i find the most peace and
understanding
sometimes i don't get any understanding
from him but
you know
i think he gets me
i think he understands us you know
it's really funny i mean like most of
the
important characters you know main
people in the bible
rahab reyap was a harlot you know mary
magdalene you know come on david he was
an adulterer you know he lusted
i mean
man there's so many
so many things
and i like stuff like that i like that
because
god
he hung out with these people he ate
with these people
you know he accepted these people i mean
you know he might have not accepted
their behaviors in their things that he
did but
he understood
he understood and he gave grace and
mercy
and
i love him for that
i just try to keep it real with god as
much as possible i know he already knows
what i'm thinking so
he's probably shaking his head at me
all right samantha thank you so much for
sharing your story absolutely i wish you
the best of luck thank you thank you
you